go home in his double elimination  tension ran high in the ballroom Tuesday  night as we said goodbye to two fan  favorites the first couple to leave us  is babyface and Allison I wasn't ready  to go Allison has just been amazing at  just getting this left foot to learn how  to dance  my two left feet and and it's been  amazing that I that that I even was able  to do any of it I owe that all to  Allison  question one couple gone one more to go  at this time it was Jenna and Gleb up  against Vanilla Ice and Whitney the next  couple leaving right now is vanilla ice  this has been a grind I mean her foot is  hurtin were bruised restore all over  we've lost tons of sleep and you know  it's it's been great because we've  fought through all this adversity and  still managed to pull off some great  routines but honestly we did Ice Ice  Baby we'll never top it so we're happy  with that problem